Mitchell Woods otherwise known as lucky
was a career Navy man but after the
green poison hit his Squadron was called
home and would leave his ship and walk
straight onto a Black Tusk hovercraft
[Music]
[Music]
the only individual in a squadron to
survive on three separate occasions
after operations went deadly Mitchell
Woods ultimately gained his namesake
lucky though the rumors that he had
obtained advancements by destroying his
Rivals was ever present as he seemed to
be indifferent towards the loss of the
Fallen men he'd served alongside in the
units it was almost too convenient their
deaths and with very little rivalry
against them he naturally progressed
over time into more distinguished roles
within the Navy
before his Squadron was summoned home in
the wake of the green poison epidemic
having spent his entire career in the
Navy he had successfully reached the
ranks of two-star Admiral and Navy SEAL
Commander yet coming home for lucky to
assist with the outbreak was unbefitting
to him why should he have to waste his
time on people and tasks far beneath his
status quo when he could be utilized and
appreciated by a far better cause and in
so many other ways
to Lucky the black tusks seem like the
superior alternative that he had been
looking for
and thus he abandoned his ship almost
immediately in favor of a Black Tusk
cover craft
as a result the rumors that had followed
him throughout his career were only
strengthened after he abandoned his post
lucky would reach out to General
Anderson regarding the hyenas
General Anderson I am pleased to inform
you that all ties between the Black Tusk
and the hyenas have now been severed we
will no longer be providing any
logistical Supply or weapons support to
the hyenas
our infrastructure they will fall into
disarray and it will be easier for us to
take back the capital without
interference thank you lucky please tell
Natalia that I'm impressed by the black
tusk's efficiency and I look forward to
collaborating with her more in the
future and the other thing consider it
taken care of
I'll give the order for my men to Grant
you clearance at the Docks so you can
assess our capabilities for yourself
this update would allow lucky access
into the true Sons where he could assess
their capabilities but shortly after
this interaction he would contact a
convoy called Roma one and reroute the
delivery
change of plans reroute Mothership
delivery to Fairview I repeat
reroute delivery to Fairview do not
proceed to 270. stay on 70 and await
further instructions
we've reached a deal with the rumors
they've agreed to transport the supplies
to Fairview but they've run into some
trouble in Virginia what kind of trouble
roadblock and hostile Convoy what do
they want for their trouble they would
like us to sweeten the deal with a
shipment of spice of course they would
do you want me to handle the
negotiations
that would be very helpful lucky
I have to get ready for my meeting with
Anderson at Fairview
tell them the spice will be waiting for
them at the plant they can pick it up as
payment on delivery
so who are these rumors I initially
heard these comms and assumed that they
were just Black Tusk with a code name
but when they made the request for spice
this doesn't fit the Remo
spice is the hyena drug of choice so
they're likely to be hyenas that they
are paying to run errands for them so as
Lucky in Natalya lying to Anderson or is
this just some sort of final job after
finishing out
I feel like this should have some
significance but I'm not quite seeing
what it is at this stage
agents would discover lucky and his
forces in East Mall Washington DC his
Black Tusk had taken control of a number
of high-value outposts across the
district
seemingly taken by surprise the shd
agents fought through recapturing the
control points for the local sediments
Lucky's location would be revealed he
was holding out in the air and space
museum
the Black Tusk presence was heavy and
well organized agents would have to take
their time clearing wave after wave in
each room they progressed through
eventually lucky would make himself
known and slowly marched towards the
agents wielding a minigun and heavy body
armor
but like all Heavy units this armor was
just fodder for gaining quick Striker
stacks and it wouldn't be long before
the agents were able to pierce through
it and eliminate him
with the final Target now eliminated
General Anderson's location has now been
revealed he is at the Fairview power
plant
but he isn't the only one there other
than the hordes of Black Tusk Natalya
and Anderson have now acted on their
suspicions around Captain Lewis
this is Fred what's wrong they know the
shoe says in Black tusker rounding up my
men taking them into custody if they try
to put up a fight to execute can he get
away no Wally she was on a supply run
maybe she's safe what do I do don't
fight go with them we'll find you the
plant they were supposed to have a meat
at the plant we'll find you just don't
do anything stupid you know me I do
that's why I have to say it again Fred
don't do anything stupid
don't try to be a hero and not today
save it for tomorrow
surrender today so I can be a hero
tomorrow
so Lewis and his men have now been
captured this mission is now more than
just about apprehending General Anderson
this is a rescue mission
thank you very much for watching an
extremist malice extrema remedia
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]